bonsoir bienvenue c'est ça vous
regardant direct je suis ravi de vous
retrouver au sommaire ce soir le coup
d'éclat permanent à l'Assemblée après la
sortie du RN jugé raciste dans
l'hémicycle signé Grégoire defournat si
elle brune TV a réuni le bureau pour
statuer sur différents débordements
récents dans l'émission cirque ou
contre-pouvoir rarement le Parlement
n'aura été aussi bruyant chaque vote et
le fruit d'une bataille épique pour le
meilleur ou pour le pire de la
démocratie grand débat dans un instant
avec nos invités sur ce plateau notre
grand témoin ce soir est écrivain et
réalisateur il avait signé une première
enquête visionnaire en 2016 sur la
dictature invisible du numérique il
revient avec un essai costumier avec
Christophe Labbé qui va beaucoup plus
loin l'homme sans contact aux éditions
de l'Observatoire ou comment
l'intelligence artificielle nos
déshumanise jusqu'à prendre le contrôle
de nos vies qui t'a nous faire
disparaître Marc du est avec nous ce
soir enfin trois affranchis trois
parties pris le regard sur le monde de
Vincent Huger qui revient ce soir sur
les résultats des meeters Américaines
l'histoire du jour au Palais Bourbon
elles amont d'un Gava nous raconter
pourquoi la présidente du groupe
d'études sur l'antisémitisme à
l'Assemblée fait l'objet d'un temps
tractation et puis le parti pris de
l'écho avec Fanny guinochet la grève de
trop demain à la RATP voilà pour le menu
c'est parti
[Musique]
avec le pouvoir viennent les
responsabilités l'assemblée donne-t-elle
une bonne image d'elle-même depuis la
nouvelle donne des législatives on va
s'arrêter ce soir sur la série de coup
d'éclats qui a transformé l'hémicycle en
véritable chaudron ces dernières
semaines le conflit la chaleur les
décibels le tout sous l'oeil des caméras
et des réseaux sociaux tout cela est-il
à la hauteur d'un parlement redevenu le
cœur de la vie politique bonsoir Antoine
Armand et merci d'être avec nous vous
êtes député Renaissance le parti
présidentiel maintenant on connaît le
nom député de Haute-Savoie bonsoir
Antoine léoman ravi de vous accueillir
député la France insoumise de l'Essonne
ancien responsable de la stratégie
numérique de la campagne présidentielle
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon n'a pas mal de
questions à vous poser ce soir bonsoir
philippe Moreau chevron ravi de vous
retrouver sur ce plateau vous êtes
communicant mcbg conseil merci d'être là
l'historien Jean garrigue va nous
rejoindre dans un tout petit instant il
est grand spécialiste de l'histoire de
la vie Parlement il nous dira si c'est
vraiment tout nouveau tout frais tout ça
tout ce théâtre dans l'hémicycles mais
d'abord le regard de Blacko pour nous
planter les décors alors bureau de
l'Assemblée aujourd'hui pour statuer sur
des débordements divers pas seulement
celui dont on a beaucoup parlé
d'ailleurs débordements des rapages
incident jugés racistes de Grégoire de
Fournas il y en a eu beaucoup d'autres
dans les jours qui ont précédé si j'ai
bien compris l'assemblée version western
le billet de Dako tout de suite
[Musique]
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Mariam bonsoir
messieurs alors si j'ai bien compris ce
soir j'ai bien compris Myriam on s'est
réjouis trop vite mais si on s'est
réjouit trop vite souvenez-vous en juin
dernier quand tu as surgit des urnes
cette magnifique hémicycle ce magnifique
hémicycle bariolé on s'est dit ça y est
les opinions de tous les Français sont
enfin représentés à l'Assemblée ça va
être bourré de débat passionnant
intéressant
depuis plusieurs mois
si ce n'est pas trop agité parce que
regardez comment le débat à l'Assemblée
représenté dans la presse là c'est le
progrès à Lyon donc voilà comment on
représente le débat des députés à la
capitale tout ça se résume donc à une
grande bataille où finalement tout le
monde s'insulte alors évidemment c'est
pas pour critiquer les journalistes je
les connais ils sont pas mauvais fonds
mais c'est vrai que une bonne baston ça
fait quand même plus d'audience qu'un
bon débat de fond sur le budget de la
Sécu résultat le fond du débat est un
petit peu éclipsé par la forme je peux
vous donner un exemple
vous êtes là pour ça en même temps donc
apparemment un mois le député du Yang du
RN Alexandre Loubet a posé une question
assez intéressante au milieu de
l'économie regardez parler d'une
entreprise qui s'appelle excelia donc je
pense que personne tout le monde a
oublié le nom de cette entreprise qui
vend des composés électroniques pour
l'armée et donc il y a une question de
souveraineté parce que ça a été racheté
par des Américains le problème c'est que
la seule chose qu'on est retenue de
cette question posée c'est quoi bah
c'est la manière dont elle était posée
avec l'insulte au ministre de l'économie
en écoute monsieur lebr vous avez
travaillé il fut un temps pour Dominique
de Villepin qui avait dénoncé la lâcheté
de ceux qui refusent de défendre les
intérêts de la France aujourd'hui le
lâche c'est vous j'ai l'honneur de
demander des excuses solennelles au
rassemblement national pour avoir
employé le terme de lâche à une personne
qui a toujours fait preuve de courage le
débat sera la souveraineté c'est
vraiment quelque chose d'intéressant
mais ça c'est pas arrêté là parce
qu'après Marine Le Pen forcément elle
est redescendu des travers elle a pas
aimé le doigt brandi Bruno Le Maire donc
elle était loin finalement là on a
finalement deux candidats pour 2027
candidat qui se dispute forcément les
télé-accordent beaucoup plus
d'importance à cette image qu'au débat
de fond qui n'était pas non plus sans
intérêt tout ça c'est pas bon quand même
pour l'image de l'Assemblée nationale
moi je pense que c'est pas bon pour le
pour l'image de l'Assemblée mais cela
dit je comprends les députés de
l'opposition c'est-à-dire que alisabeth
borne a déjà sorti 4 fois le 49-3 donc à
un moment on se demande mais à quoi bon
proposer des abonnements bon moi je vous
prends l'exemple d'un dos de l'autre
jour le député et les filles votre
collègue Rodrigo Arenas il a carrément
quitté la commission discuter du budget
de l'éducation l'éducation c'est sa
passion c'est un mec de la FCPE il a
vraiment beaucoup de trucs à dire
là-dessus et il apprend qu'on en
discutera même pas dans l'hémicycle donc
à quoi bon on discuter un Commission on
regarde
pour le groupe et les filles nous allons
prendre congé de cette commission et
nous espérons que dans l'avenir nous
pourrons avoir un débat démocratique
dans lequel le Parlement sera respecté
et dans lequel la diversité de nos rangs
sera pris en compte dans les dans les
politiques Amiens on vous remercie
merci monsieur le député
un scoop c'est une image que vous verrez
que sur elle fait le travail des député
en commission on en parle pas pourtant
moi qui suis un peu novice dans le
domaine mais je suis bluffé par le
travail que fournisse mais l'ensemble
des députés quand vous regardez en
commission les gens sont passionnés par
leur par leur boulot donc
malheureusement la seule chose qu'on
retient de l'extérieur ce sont les
polémiques croisés relayées par les
réseaux sociaux donc ce pauvre enfin je
dis ce pauvre gentiment Rodrigo Arenas
il s'est dit bon bah puisqu'on parle pas
de moi faut que je crée un événement
donc le lendemain il s'est présenté dans
l'hémicycle avec ce brassard en grève du
coup il y a LeBron privé le dit c'est
pas autorisé par le règlement il a été
puni mais au moins il a eu sa photo dans
le journal il a un peu fait parler de sa
colère quoi vous écoutez l'assemblée est
paralysée par ces tensions oui non mais
pas forcément bah vous savez donc
qu'est-ce que je fais je parle des
trains qui arrivent en retard mais il y
a aussi quelques trains qui arrivent
alors regardez aujourd'hui ça c'est
c'est pas très sexy comme texte pourtant
ça veut dire qu'il y a une commission
mix parité donc sénateur et vraiment
dire qu'ils sont réunis aujourd'hui donc
la majorité et les républicains sont
tombés d'accord sur un texte sur
l'assurance chômage oui c'est un petit
peu le projet de Sarkozy qui est en
train de se profiler donc est-ce que la
paix une alliance
par contre c'est ça le truc c'est que la
gauche en tout cas la partie je sais pas
si c'est toujours Jean-Luc Mélenchon le
patron doit les filles mais si c'est
toujours lui il a pas de scalpé selon
l'intention de la baiser le débat
regarder moi je crois toujours à la
Révolution je crois toujours que il faut
l'onde de choc de la révolution n'est
pas épuisée la bataille générale doit
commencer je vous fais pas non plus
on a le sentiment que le programme ça
peut aussi être de bousculer le
Parlement jusqu'à faire éclater la
colère dans la rue alors est-ce que le
pouvoir est dans la rue
qui est à l'Assemblée c'est à nous
débattre c'est à vous messieurs merci
merci pour ce billet piquant et enlever
comme comme chaque soir Antoine le mot
je vais je vais commencer par vous
trois membres dont deux avec inscription
au procès-verbal en quelques semaines
seulement il y en a un contre le
rassemblement national avec sandre
Loubet montrer du doigt vengeur on l'a
vu par Bruno Le Maire pour avoir
prononcé ce mot de lâche il y en a une
autre un autre contre votre collègue
insoumise de Daniel obono on a vu
Rodrigo Arenas avec son son brassard en
grade est-ce que c'est c'est ça le
nouveau Parlement est-ce que l'invective
et le et le chahut c'est une technique
alors peut-être un peu ancienne mais que
vous réactivez à des saints
volontairement dans l'opposition c'est
pas ça et je pense que dans la chronique
qu'on vient d'entendre il y avait un
point qui était quand même assez
intéressant et votre collègue l'a dit
c'est aussi la presse s'intéresse
davantage à ce genre de situation que au
travail parlementaire assez fréquemment
on va prendre ce qui s'est mal passé ce
qui a fait une expression mais en
quelque sorte parce que à l'intérieur de
l'Assemblée nationale des sujets de
polémique des sujets de tension il en
existe depuis que l'Assemblée nationale
existe je veux pas remonter jusqu'à la
l'évolution de 1789
je sais que sur LCP c'est un peu
différent mais c'est vrai que il y a une
partie de la presse qui apprécie quand
c'est sanglant quand il y a de la baston
parce que votre collègue a dit ça fait
vendre davantage de papier et ça ça
intéresse peut-être évidemment je vais
vous montrer mais je vous interroge je
vous donne la parole on va
regarder Daniel au Bono
man
ifeste n'a pas supporté une une question
sur les violences sexuelles on était en
pleine affaire Catena se regarder elle a
elle a du mal à se faire respecter il y
a LeBron pile est obligé de sortir le
carton rouge je précise qu'en
application de l'article 71 du règlement
je prononce un rappel à l'ordre à votre
rencontre
[Applaudissements]
madame
vous continuez à Universe
si c'est ce que vous faites
donc je prononce un rappel à l'ordre
avec inscription au procès-verbal
[Applaudissements]
vous savez ce que dit Marine Le Pen de
cette séquence et d'autres en général
sur la stratégie des filles elle est fi
fait du TikTok quand il parle il nous
parle pas parlons des collègues pas
uniquement le RN député il parle à leurs
réseaux sociaux est-ce qu'il a pas un
petit peu raison là peut-être que Marine
Le Pen est jalouse du fait que nous
avons des réseaux sociaux qui
fonctionnent mais pour revenir sur le
cas de Daniel obono en réalité qu'est-ce
qui se passait on avait une polémique
qui était créée de toutes pièces sur une
polémique qui était politicienne oui ou
les questions des violences sexistes
étaient sexuelles étaient utilisées
contre le groupe de la France insoumise
et donc Daniel au Bono Daniel Daniel
obono dans ce qu'elle disait elle disait
où est le milliard contre les violences
sexistes et sexuelles parce que c'est
bien beau de parler mais ensuite sur les
actes il n'y a jamais eu ce milliard
d'euros qui a été voté par les députés
de la majorité alors que nous avons
déposé des amendements depuis quatre ans
sur le sujet donc la stratégie Tik Tok
c'est pas la vôtre il est vrai que nous
faisons des vidéos mais attendez nous
faisons des vidéo pour faire sortir ce
qui se passe de l'hémicycle vers la
société mais parce qu'il est important
que les gens qui ne suivent pas
forcément les débats parlementaires
puissent avoir du contenu qui arrive sur
les réseaux sociaux et qui informe sur
ce qui se passe à l'Assemblée nationale
mais nous nous essayons pas de faire des
déclin nous essayons de faire en sorte
que ce qui est dit dans l'Assemblée
nationale en sorte pour que les gens
puissent ensuite prendre des décisions
sur des bases qui sont qu'on fait mes
députés à l'Assemblée nationale Antoine
vous c'est votre premier mandat quand on
regarde l'assemblée franchement il y a
pas grand chose de nouveau je sais du
jean garrigue notre
historien favori qui va qui va nous le
dire dans un instant
vous vous trouvez que on a franchi un
cran franchement ou c'est la présidente
qui a peut-être du mal à se faire
respecter moi j'ai été élu à 30 ans
c'est mon premier mandat en connaissant
un peu le la vie publique et je trouve
qu'il y a deux choses fondamentalement
différentes il y a la première chose que
qu'évoquait mon collègue au manque qui
est celle de faire connaître les débats
et donc effectivement essayer de faire
connaître plutôt les débats en
commission ou même les débats qu'on a eu
hier sur le budget rectificatif de une
aide spécifique pour les Français qui se
chauffent au pellet qui sont dans une
situation extrêmement délicate ça
nourrit des débats on finit par voter un
amendement de l'opposition on a un débat
constructif c'est un peu complexe mais
contrairement à ce qu'on dit les
Français s'intéressent toujours beaucoup
plus au fond que ce qu'on croit et bien
sûr que le spécialiste
quand elle prend la parole sur la
question des femmes notamment elle a
elle a aussi conscience des caméras ça
n'a rien à voir parce qu'il y a deux
choses différentes et la deuxième chose
qui est différente c'est celle du
respect des règles parce qu'en fait
quand on ne respecte pas les règles
internes à l'Assemblée celle du
règlement qui sont celles votées par les
députés et donc celle qui sont encadrées
par notre Constitution les personnes
qu'on ne respecte pas ce sont pas les
députés de la majorité à qui on veut
faire comprendre que vraiment ils ont
rien compris à la vie c'est les Français
c'est les gens qui nous ont élu et quand
on respecte pas les règles dans notre
assemblée dans notre hémicycle c'est à
la démocratie qu'on dit nous on s'en
abstrait parce qu'on est au-dessus de ça
nous on a raison et on a tellement
raison qu'on a le droit de pas respecter
les règles de notre vie commune comment
on voit le communicant ce qui se passe
dans l'émission
les Français ont choisi cette assemblée
une assemblée différente qu'il est
représente davantage sans majorité
absolue est-ce qu'il s'attendent ça ce
genre d'invective ou est-ce que c'est
désastreux en terme d'image les Français
ont une relation très ambiguë avec le
Parlement ils aiment bien le Parlement
ils aiment bien en avoir mais ils aiment
pas trop effectivement les images de
désordre et d'engueulades le problème
c'est qu'un Parlement qui va bien c'est
un parlement qui s'engueule c'est un
parlement où s'invective c'est un
parlement où on est mal peigné c'est pas
un parlement bien rangé avec ce qu'on a
appelé des députés Playmobil on peut
dire ça beaucoup de majorité c'est pas
que la majorité en marche toutes les
majorités sont un peu Playmobil là on a
retrouvé une vitalité démocratique donc
les Français peuvent s'en réjouir le
truc c'est que il y a un problème dans
le problème c'est un peu une poupée
russe le vrai problème c'est que vous
avez une stratégie qui est celle du RN
et qui joue le bon élève et qui surjoue
le côté cravate et le côté voilà
sympathique gentil frappe sur lui
jusqu'à quel âge une saillie
je reviens au galop mais l'image que les
Français ont eu du début du mandat on va
dire parlementaire des reines c'est des
gens sérieux qui bossent et une
stratégie éléfique et plus une stratégie
d'agit de propre que moi je comprends
parce que c'est la culture de la gauche
et qu'après tout on est là pour se faire
entendre parler au réseau sociaux par
ailleurs le RN devrait le faire je suis
désolé mais tous les médias enfin tous
les parlementaires en dehors de la
France utilisent des réseaux sociaux
constamment pour expliquer ce qu'ils
font ils le font la caméra
elle parle à la caméra elle parle pas
aux 50 Pékin qui sont en face d'elle et
c'est pas grave c'est normal mais après
le truc c'est voilà c'est la stratégie
d'image et c'est vrai que les Français
vont peut-être plus savoir tendance à
récompenser le RN et les bons élèves
parce que c'est surprenant c'est
intéressant il y a un enjeu de
gouvernement d'ailleurs ça François
Ruffin doit et les filles très justement
dit peut-être qu'il faut qu'on en tire
une conséquence et c'est là où
finalement l'Assemblée nationale c'est
comme le lieu où on aime la politique
c'est que ça change voilà stratégie
s'adapte
merci d'être là votre nouvelle opus le
30e me disiez vous tout à l'heure il
était contre Matignon de 58 à nos jours
chez thaïlandais viens de sortir le
couple infernal ce qu'on voit dans
l'émission est-ce que c'est vraiment
nouveau évidemment c'est pas nouveau
c'est pas nouveau du tout il suffit de
se référer à la Révolution française ou
à 3e république quand les députés
extrêmes vont des gifler le ministre de
l'Intérieur moment de la faire des
fiches ou quand en 1936 un député
extrême droite disait ce vieux pays
gallo-romain va être gouverné par un
juif parlant de Léon Blum qui devait
d'être investi
plus tard donc les débats sur l'IVG la
loi veille 74
les insultes
antisémites on a tous donc ça c'est pas
tellement nouveau mais je rejoins ce qui
a été dit le problème c'est qu'on est
dans un moment à mon sens charnière
c'est un moment où l'enjeu pour les
politiques dans leur ensemble c'est un
enjeu de relégitimation par rapport aux
Français par rapport aux citoyens bon la
chance qui est donnée aux acteurs
politiques aujourd'hui c'est d'avoir des
élections législatives qui ont été un
peu à contretemps de ce qui était la
logique de l'hyper président du fait
majoritaire avec une vraie opposition
qui peut faire entendre sa voix ce qui
était pas le cas dans le quinquennat
précédent donc il me semble que dans
cette perspective là il faut la jouer
quand même un peu plus fine que
simplement la stratégie de
conflictualité je alors de porter un
jugement critique ou bon mais il me
semble que et c'est ce que me semble
disent les sondages aujourd'hui vous
disiez oui le les français portent
plutôt crédit aux Front national
rassemblement national d'abord j'ai
cette carte du bon élève mais c'est un
peu ce qui se passe et je pense que la
et d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'a compris
François Ruffin il me semble que c'est
normal
enfin justement qui a questionné
publiquement à la stratégie on va dire
de la conflictualité au sein de son
groupe
ça ne sert à rien
c'est plutôt le fait qu'ils en ont
rajouté dans l'indiscipline et la
conflictualité je pense qu'elle est bien
elle est bien venue au contraire la
stratégie c'est ce qui était théorisé
par le LFI c'est pourquoi moi je c'est
une stratégie politique on peut la
comprendre mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que on est Ruffin Ruffin ce qui
faisait la l'intérêt de du
positionnement de François Ruffin on en
parlait tout à l'heure avec le député
les filles c'était qu'il était capable
de porter au sein de l'hémicycle des
enjeux sociaux que les autres ne
portaient pas je pense que là on est
dans un frérot une partie il y a des il
y a des réflexions et des doutes sur une
stratégie
au moment du pouvoir d'achat par exemple
à l'été dernier et aujourd'hui est-ce
que vous avez l'impression que appelons
le bruit et la fureur peut-être pour
reprendre l'expression de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon vous vous interrogez sur cette
stratégie et vous voulez vous concentrer
sur le fond peut-être davantage alors
déjà on sait toujours concentré sur le
fond je rappelle que pendant le projet
de loi pouvoir d'achat je mets des gros
guillemets sur pouvoir d'achat parce que
je crois pas que le pouvoir d'achat des
Français est énormément évolué depuis
cette loi nous avions déposé un grand
nombre d'amendements précisément pour
porter le sujet sur le fond d'un côté on
nous proposait des primes et de
l'intéressement à la participation des
entreprises et nous nous disions non ce
n'est pas ça la question la question est
celle des salaires et de l'augmentation
des salaires
pour rebondir sur ça précisément vous
avez aussi dans cette stratégie là vous
avez déposé plusieurs amendements le
même amendement disant que la prime
Macron il fallait la rebaptiser une
prime d'amphumage on avait déposé
c'est une stratégie d'obstruction
d'harceler un peu la majorité d'une
manière de faire des choses piquante ce
que je vous le disais au début mais on
connaît aussi comment fonctionne la
presse si jamais on veut attirer
l'attention parfois il faut faire des
trucs un peu piquants de ce type là qui
permettent de faire émerger un sujet
mais sur le fond nous travaillons à
chaque fois amendement rebaptisé à
redéposer plusieurs fois ça vous le
ferait c'est possible par exemple sur la
question de la réforme des traits en
fait il y a des temps sur la question du
pouvoir d'achat ils nous semblait qu'il
y a une urgence qui est celle de
l'augmentation des salaires et vous avez
eu en dans les mois qui viennent de
s'écouler des grosses greffes qui
portaient précisément la question de
l'augmentation des salaires et du
partage de la valeur parce qu'il est
insupportable qu'une entreprise comme
Total réalise des super profits et d'un
autre côté ne paye pas d'impôts face du
rachat d'action pour 2 milliards d'euros
ce qui correspond à 80 000 euros par
salarié dans notre pays et que on nous
dise non il n'est pas possible
d'augmenter salaire donc il y avait une
urgence quand il y a une urgence de ce
type là notre rôle est aussi de faire
entendre la colère du peuple à
l'intérieur de l'Assemblée nationale sur
la question de la bataille des retraites
qui arrivent sur la retraite à 65 ans
est-ce que les Français comprendraient
que nous soyons là en train de
co-construire des lois avec lesquelles
nous ne sommes pas d'accord bien sûr que
non nous les Français attendent de nous
que nous défendions les positions que
nous avons défendues pendant les
élections législatives à savoir la
retraite à 60 ans et les moyens de
financer cette retraite à 60 ans mais il
y a des temps et il y a un temps il a
des temps de batailles qui sont des
batailles assez dures assez fortes et
dans laquelle je pense c'est un avis
personnel mais je crois qui peut être
partagé que la colère populaire qui
existe contre la politique
gouvernementale doit être entendue y
compris à l'intérieur de l'Assemblée
nationale
a été pensé il est réfléchi et on se
rend compte en travaillant un peu ce
sujet que il n'est pas forcément
typiquement insoumis il vient de plus
loin vous connaissez seul Aline ski
c'est un sociologue américain qui a
théorisé le community organizing qui
exactement ce que vient d'écrire Antoine
et au Mans aller chercher la colère des
classes populaires souvent éloignées des
bureaux de vote et qui ont besoin d'être
représentés avec un relais de leurs
indignations c'est une manière
totalement loi de faire la politique non
absolument pas parce que c'est justement
ce que disait monsieur Chevrolet tout à
l'heure il s'agit d'agit de propre et
d'agit propre et de populisme en fait
c'est-à-dire que qu'est-ce que vous
faites vous prenez une situation
complexe la situation de l'inflation
qu'on redécouvre et vous cherchez un
discours simpliste pour pouvoir avoir
une résonance une résonance la plus
large possible et donc vous dites on va
augmenter les salaires augmentons tous
les salaires qu'est-ce qui va se passer
on aura une spirale inflationniste on
aura deux fois plus d'inflation on aura
des entreprises qui auront plus de
compétitivité et des salariés qui n'ont
pas gagné de pouvoir d'achat mais je
reviens sur ce que je viens de dire mon
collègue est vraiment parce que c'est
extrêmement intéressant vous avez là un
expert et je le reconnais d'ailleurs en
communication et en fait on n'a pas du
tout et on le sent dans l'hémicycle chez
les filles à faire à un parti de
gouvernement on a affaire à un parti
agit propre qui organise la colère qui
met en scène une existence légitime de
contestation mais qui n'a en aucun cas
alors même si une petite difficulté à
accepter d'être l'opposition
parce que il y a des jours où on
reconnaît il y a des jours où elle est
fille reconnaissent à défaite et puis
des jours où il se présente majoritaire
et donc c'est très intéressant on n'a
pas à faire un parti de gouvernement on
a affaire à un parti je reprends
l'expression elle est trop excellente
elle s'est passé d'agit
c'est une accusation qui est toujours
faite par les pouvoirs en place contre
les pouvoirs alternatifs pas du tout
socialiste dans la campagne président
oui mais un le Parti Socialiste n'a pas
fait un score qui lui permettait d'être
un parti de gouvernement c'était notre
cas à nous avons fait un score qui nous
permettait d'obtenir un second tour et
d'obtenir la victoire à l'élection
présidentielle puis ensuite et nous
l'avons démontré d'ailleurs d'être la
force arriver en tête au premier tour de
l'élection législative donc nous sommes
un parti de gouvernement sur la capacité
électorale ce n'est pas le rassemblement
national d'ailleurs puisque à chaque
fois qu'il arrive à un second tour il se
fait battre par le la personne qui est
face à lui mais nous sommes un parti de
gouvernement puisque nous avons
travaillé un programme qui est un
programme d'ensemble et quand vous dites
que nous faisons des choses qui sont
simplistes ça n'est pas le cas parce que
par exemple sur notre proposition
d'augmentation des salaires elle est
assortie du fait de mettre en place de
protectionnisme solidaire qui fasse en
sorte la production
d'ausculer la manière le Parlement
existe bien sûr je vais très rapidement
sur ça mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que nous avons aussi chiffré notre
programme nous avons fait en sorte de
proposer nous avons fait en sorte de
proposer aux Français au programme
global on ne peut pas prendre et c'est
précisément pour ça que je vous reprends
sur la mesure simpliste parce qu'on ne
peut pas prendre une mesure séparée de
notre programme elle fonctionne ensemble
elle fonctionne en tout et par ailleurs
nous l'avons chiffré nous nous sommes
préparés à gouverner le pays maintenant
il est un peu facile de nous raconter
vous êtes dans l'opposition dans la
contestation mais dans aussi dans
l'alternative on a compris Jean Gary on
est prêt je vais vous montrer une petite
séquence et là peut-être que c'est
nouveau elle concerne aussi le
comportement des insoumis dans
l'hémicycle la député insoumise à ma
Dufour jeune député a rencontré de
manière fortuite la première ministre
dans un endroit où les caméras ne sont
pas autorisées regardez ce que ça donne
téléphone smartphone à l'appui
49-3 quand le climat du coup c'est ça
15 minutes et c'était historique madame
vraiment
que vous faites la suppression de la
CVAE franchement
je sais pas quoi
les dépenses de révolution scientifique
le disent et ça on peut pas dépenser 13
milliards la première année mais c'était
gagée on pouvait le dépenser la deuxième
chose
voilà c'est pas une activiste du climat
là qui rencontre la première ministre
elle a été mais c'est une représentante
de la nation alors la première nuit elle
a vu le téléphone en train de en train
de filmer mais c'est complètement
nouveau là alors là on n'avait jamais vu
ça avant est-ce que vous trouvez ça
normal légitime bon ça c'est
l'adaptation à cette époque des réseaux
sociaux ça me choque pas forcément parce
que au fond ça a toujours existé aussi
alors avant c'était dans les couloirs de
la du palais Bourmont ou les types qui
étaient de parties de changer
ça se retrouvait dans la presse parce
qu'il y avait une presse notamment
parlementaire qui est beaucoup plus
actif qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup plus
présente une presse écrite et puis dans
des mémoires DES JOURNAUX ETC non on a
toujours trouvé ça des confidences sur
ce qui pouvait se dire de manière plus
ou moins secrète en tout cas
non-officiel moi ça me choque pas
véritablement dans ce qui me ce qui me
choque moi c'est la difficulté à je
dirais
j'insiste là dessus légitimer ce qui est
en train de se faire et la chance
historique que à travers ces
institutions de la Cinquième République
qui dont l'usage notamment depuis une
dizaine d'années a été dévoyé à mon sens
on ne saisit pas véritablement cette
chance je comprends la stratégie de
conflictualité au fond c'était celle du
Parti communiste pendant pendant 5 ans
fonction de protestataire tribunicienne
ça a été un moment celle de des poujadis
dans les années 50 si vous voulez ça
c'est pas c'est pas quelque chose qui
qui me choque on est même si c'était
très difficile c'était très des idées
très différentes de vous mais moi
j'essaie d'analyser en prendre un peu de
recul donc ça ça me paraît pas ça me
paraît pas choquant si vous voulez
j'ai l'impression que là on est
particulièrement sur le regard de
l'opinion d'une certaine façon voilà les
députés sont pas d'une certaine façon à
la hauteur de la de la promesse de cette
nouvelle assemblée en même temps
philippe Moreau Chevrolet les textes
passent alors à plus de 49,3 pour
l'instant la plupart qu'il y a eu
beaucoup de textes budgétaires pas
seulement on le voit sur l'assurance
chômage on l'a vu aussi sur quel autre
texte aidez-moi le budget rectificatif
hier soir
d'une certaine manière
les réformes avancent et pas forcément
trop lentement ça se voit pas forcément
par rapport à tous ces coups d'éclats
finalement est-ce que c'est pas c'est
pas un problème et là il y a un clivage
qui est en train de se reconstituer
l'immense avantage de éléphant et de
cette stratégie c'est qu'il y a une
conflictualité donc avant il y en avait
pas quand même là il y en a une donc ça
fait qu'on a un retour du de l'équilibre
droit de gauche qui est jamais vraiment
disparu mais on le voit mieux avec une
alliance clairement de droite alors avec
elle entre Renaissance et l'air par
exemple parfois étendu au RN et puis en
face un bloc qui est vraiment désigné
comme l'adversaire par le chef de l'État
par la majorité qui est la nuque moi je
trouve ça très bien
je dis juste je dis juste qu'on retrouve
un clivage droite-gauche pourquoi c'est
intéressant et pourquoi c'est bien parce
que ce qui provoque la montée des
extrêmes c'est le fait de dire que tout
se vaut là au moins on a des vraies
différences après ça va on ne sens pas
aider la nuque à devenir un parti de
gouvernement c'est plutôt même l'inverse
mais en attendant globalement je pense
que c'est plutôt mieux pour la société
le problème que soulève jungle et
intéressant c'est qu'on a une situation
différente parce que ce que je viens de
dire c'est dans l'absolu en particulier
en 2022 moi si je fais un observateur je
me dis qu'en 2027 il va être extrêmement
compliqué de pas avoir Marine Le Pen
comme président de la République avec
une majorité derrière parce que là ils
sont en train de se construire une
crédibilité de fou la faute à qui ils
ont des postes l'Assemblée nationale il
commence à les exercer par contraste
effectivement avec quel efficace à aller
chercher l'électorat populaire et les
filles a beaucoup réussi dans cette
élection législative cette année vous
avez fait mais c'est ça pas toujours
effet été facile pour vous et le renne a
plus de facilité à le faire donc pour
aussi un vrai risque que ce qu'on soit
en train de construire c'est une c'est
pas seulement une montée c'est une
installation au pouvoir de Marine Le Pen
en 2000 en 2027
vous partagez ça ce serait uniquement la
faute
de la nuque beaucoup de modestie sur les
responsabilités les oppositions de
gauche vous accuse aussi de ne pas avoir
été assez clair dans l'entre deux tours
des législatives dans les duels
premièrement ça fait des décennies qui
est un député raciste qui a été élu à
l'Assemblée nationale il y avait face à
lui un candidat ou une candidat tenue
pèse je me souviens plus qu'elle était
mais il y a pas eu de consignes de vente
il y a pas une consigne de premièrement
premièrement premièrement soyons
modestes sur l'attribution de
responsabilité ça fait des décennies que
l'extrême droite monte pack en France en
Europe soyons un petit peu modeste moi
juste deux chiffres qui m'ont énormément
marqué et qui me blesse je vous le dis
et parce que je n'ai jamais confondu ni
la France insoumise ni la nuit Pesse
avec le Front national enfin le
rassemblement national nouveau terme et
je suis pas prêt de le faire et j'espère
ne jamais peut pas le faire mais deux
chiffres qui me blessent le premier
c'est que sur les 400 sur 400 votes vous
avez 44% du temps elle est fi RN qui
vote ensemble le deuxième c'est qu'à la
dernière motion de censure la moitié des
voix de la motion de censure de LFI
venait du rassemblement national et ça
je n'ai pas d'autres mots d'être pantois
et navré l'argument et on l'a eu ce
débat je vous assure que tous les
élections répondu là-dessus rapidement
parce que je voudrais vous montrer un
dernier épisode les chiffres sont encore
pire pour vous c'est à dire vous avez
encore plus un pourcentage encore plus
ici de moins de vie vous avez encore un
pourcentage encore plus élevé de vote
avec le rassemblement national et par
exemple je très très vite mais sur la
question de l'augmentation du SMIC vous
avez voté avec le racisme
ça s'appelle une nouvelle donne
politique
dernier élément je voudrais vous vous
entendre là-dessus parce qu'on a compris
qu'il y a différents styles dans ce
mystique il faut en réjouir de ces
styles très différents mais par contre
il y a des styles vestimentaires qui
parfois ne passent pas des députés RN
cravatés aux élus d'outre-mer en chemise
à fleurs des insoumis chemises
retroussées bureau politique aujourd'hui
qui s'est mis d'accord sur un certain
nombre de nouvelles règles qui peut
porter quoi à l'assemblée de vestiaires
autorisé on voit cela avec Marco Polo
la bille est-il politique à l'Assemblée
les polémiques vestimentaires sont
récurrentes François Ruffin et son
maillot de football moi thaï brotherson
et sa chemise polynésienne ou encore
Patrice Carvalho député ouvrier et
communiste il enfile son bleu de travail
en 1997 pour sa première séance dans
l'hémicycle je suis propre
j'ai eu ma cravate alors quelles sont
les règles ce matin les députés se sont
prononcés en faveur de la veste
obligatoire dans l'hémicycle tenue
vestimentaire convenable non détendu et
pas négligé précise le bureau de
l'Assemblée oubliés donc le short ou le
bermuda un costume un col roulé pas de
cravate est-ce que pour vous vous êtes
dans les clous
mais je ne pensais pas que vous alliez
me déshabiller de la sorte enfin me
rhabiller en l'occurrence quand on est
parlementaire on se doit de respecter la
solennité des lieux l'espace c'est tout
à fait je suis entièrement d'accord avec
ça mais qui est cette police de la mode
ça m'embête le débat il est devenu très
politique tout simplement parce que les
insoumis refusent d'une certaine façon
ce code qui est accepté par tout le
monde code vestimentaire qui interdit
aussi les signes religieux
ostensibles les slogans politiques ou
encore les uniformes professionnels la
tenue doit être neutre et ne pas
manifester d'opinion quant à la cravate
elle est désormais simplement
recommandée moi je veux bien que les
mecs mettent la cravate ça me va bien
cravate or not cravate marine Le Pen a
tranché l’été dernier pour leur premier
jour à l'Assemblée les députés du
rassemblement national sont priés de la
mettre Éric ciotiv carrément la rendre
obligatoire dans son viseur la France
insoumise leur relâchement vestimentaire
fait réagir jusqu'au banc de la majorité
on est dans la représentation nationale
députée de la République enfin je veux
dire c'est pas une discothèque c'est pas
Intervilles il y a un minimum à
respecter la cravate tout un symbole en
1985 déjà Jack Lang n'en portait pas le
ministre de la Culture provoqué alors la
colère des députés de droite avec sa
veste col mao
excellent sujet Marco pommier Jean
garrigue là encore la mémoire de la vie
parlementaire donc on a compris ces
vestes obligatoires et cravates plutôt
conseillées il est il est nouveau ce
débat là sur la tenue des députés oui il
est quand même sous cette forme
provocation d'ericciotti en vue du
congrès de enfin de l'élection du
président des républicains ça c'est une
chose qui paraît évidente on est dans un
débat quand même qui est qui est un peu
secondaire on va dire même si évidemment
on y
[Musique]
à cette idée là il lui doit une forme de
respect vestimentaire un peu comme moi
quand j'allais faire mes cours à mes
étudiants je me mettais pas en général
en T-shirt pourquoi pas je veux dire que
je pense pas que ça les aurait choqué
les étudiants d'aujourd'hui je pense pas
que ça les aurait choqué mais ce que je
veux dire c'est je pense qu'il faut
garder une certaine voilà une certaine
descente par rapport à ce que la vie la
manière dont on se présente c'est aussi
une question
je pense que les Français sont peut-être
un peu évolué dans le représentation du
parlementaire après si on prend par
exemple les l'exemple espagnol quand la
nouvelle génération de parlementaires
plutôt à gauche est venue au Parlement
il y avait une mère qui allaitait son
son bébé moi je trouvais ça magnifique
comme symbole et pourquoi pas avoir ça
dans l'hémicycle on imagine
je pense qu'il y a il y a aussi une
volonté de représenter davantage aux
électeurs les électeurs ne s'habillent
plus comme autrefois systématiquement
pour les événements
du RN c'est d'avoir joué là-dessus
justement pour en rajouter dans la bonne
tenue pour montrer un contraste ça c'est
intelligent ils ont choisi quelque chose
mais dans la réalité les Français
avec son maillot de foot je pense qu'il
m'a des points pour conclure vraiment
quelques secondes sur ces questions
vestimentaires je pense que vraiment
c'est le sujet qui n'intéresse pas les
Français c'est à dire que les Français
ils veulent des augmentations de salaire
et voilà la question qui intéresse les
Français
c'est pas le sujet ou pas cravate c'est
pas le sujet ils veulent des députés qui
sont présents et qui travaillent au
service de de leurs intérêts à eux
d'accord pour conclure les Français
veulent des députés qui les respectent
et quand on est dans l'hémicycle on
s'habille correctement merci beaucoup
merci d'avoir participé à ce débat qui
ont compris sur la forme dit beaucoup du
fond aussi de cette assemblée on va
accueillir à présent notre grand témoin
il est écrivain réalisateur il avait
signé une première enquête en 2016 sur
la dictature invisible du numérique qui
s'est révélée vision son nouvel essai
avec le journaliste d'investigation
Christophe Labbé va plus loin l'homme
sans contact aux éditions de
l'Observatoire décrit comment
l'intelligence artificielle nous
déshumanise jusqu'à prendre le contrôle
de nos vies Marc Dugain nous rejoindre
juste après l'invitation signée ce soir
par Marion becquet
si on vous invite Marc Duguin c'est pour
votre nouvelle essai sur la dictature du
numérique l'homme sans contact un homme
déshumanisé depuis le confinement un
homme qui travaille à distance comment
de tout en un clic se soignant visio
n'échange plus que sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est là où une société du futur
que vous dessinez avec le journaliste
d'investigation Christophe Labbé
vous Marc Dugain vous êtes réalisateur
romancier aux multiples prix littéraires
6 ans après l'homme nu sur la dictature
du numérique vous récidivez avec l'homme
sans contact et vous analysions
apocalyptique qui n'est pas sans
rappeler le roman de George Orwell 1984
surveillance couvre-feu le roman semble
plus actuel que jamais
ce piège qui nous attend celui de
l'illusion de liberté de notre
déshumanisation de notre transformation
en consommateur addict vous le décrivez
avec précision nous aurons été les
apprentis sorciers d'un désastre pour
notre espèce la numérisation du monde
gouvernée par l'intelligence
artificielle dites-vous face à ce que
vous décrivez cette évolution qui semble
inexorable Marc Dugain est-il trop tard
pour un sursaut
bonsoir Marc Dugain et merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation alors
avant de répondre à cette question
est-il trop tard pour un sursaut quels
sont les solutions si on existe pour
mettre à distance un peu ce monstre
numérique on peut l'utiliser cette
expression va on va revenir au
diagnostic il y a 6 ans dans l'homme nu
vous allez retiriez contre cette
dictature invisible du numérique et 6
ans après L'Homme sans contact apparaît
alors sans mémoire programmée sous
surveillance et plus seul que jamais
c'est ça qu'on est devenu déjà
aujourd'hui une certaine façon mais
c'est vrai que quand on a fait le livre
il y a 6 ans c'est ça 2016
c'était c'est on ne savait pas du tout
qui allait y avoir la crise sanitaire et
la crise sanitaire a été un accélérateur
incroyable d'ailleurs une divine
surprise pour le patron de divine
opportunité la divine surprise c'était
les mots du président de Google
et c'est vrai que bon ça pour le coup on
l'avait pas vu arriver mais d'un seul
coup d'ailleurs on l'a vu dans la
valorisation des sociétés du numérique
d'un seul coup le le numérique était
déjà dans nos vies a fait une deuxième
entrée fracassante une accélération une
accélération considérable et aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que moi je me pose des
questions parce que je suis très
sensible à deux sujets qui sont le
climat et le numérique qui sont pour moi
les sujets d'avenir il est évident que
sur le climat on a pris 30 ans de retard
sur le numérique je pense qu'on est en
train de faire la même chose
c'est-à-dire que le numérique c'est une
technologie je suis pas du tout
technophobe moi je connais tous les
avantages du numérique et je les
reconnais c'est pas la question ce que
je crois c'est que le numérique est en
train et dans une vitesse et dans une
accélération qui n'a rien à voir avec le
temps politique
c'est à dire que les gens qui dirigent
les grandes sociétés numérique vont à
une vitesse qui n'est pas celle de nos
dirigeants et je pense que décennies
d'avance sur le temps politique d'une
certaine façon le pétrole a envahi nos
vies d'une façon très intéressante parce
que ça nous a donné beaucoup de confort
de mobilité beaucoup de choses très
positives aujourd'hui il est tellement
partout qu'on arrive aujourd'hui qu'on
arrive qu'on n'arrive plus à s'en
dépêtrer parce que c'est bien ça le
problème et je pense que pour le
numérique ça va être la même chose et
moi je regrette que dans une démocratie
que la note ou en plus on a une
constitution avec un président qui est
un peu au dessus de la mêlée quand ce
soit pas consacré et je crois qu'Edouard
Philippe d'ailleurs l'avait reconnu en
disant on sait pas assez consacré aux
grandes questions de long terme
au niveau européen on va on va en parler
le pire pour vous c'est l'intelligence
artificielle
en quoi c'est si dangereux pour vous
parce que c'est vrai que avec
l'intelligence artificielle il n'y a pas
que les objets connectés ou la voiture
autonome il y a aussi par exemple la
médecine préventive qui peut anticiper
prévenir de certaines maladies très
graves pour vous c'est le pire des
projets de société que porte cette
révolution alors l'intelligence
artificielle exactement comme le
numérique dont elle est le produit
elle a énormément d'avantages et c'est
toujours pareil c'est que dans nos
sociétés dans un premier temps on voit
les avantages et puis le temps passeon
on découvre les inconvénients c'est ce
qui s'est passé qu'une numérique on a vu
les avantages tout de suite moi je m'en
souviens puisque je fais partie de la
génération qui a enfin je suis pas le
seul mais qui a vu arriver le numérique
et j'ai vu tous les avantages de
connexion ça a été une accélération de
l'information et de la circulation de la
communication sans précédent avec
beaucoup de choses très très positives
par ailleurs ce qu'on n'a pas vu venir
euh et on l'a vu progressivement mais
avec retard c'est qu'une société de
surveillance est mise en place dont
aujourd'hui la Chine est le meilleur
exemple avec le Crédit social
c'est-à-dire que les gens sont
surveillés en permanence sont notés et
deviennent des citoyens totalement
contrôlésica qui a montré que les
données personnelles de Facebook avait
été utilisé tout ça était établi et
d'une certaine façon le numérique nous
nous enferme dans un entre soi orienté
vers ce qu'on aime manger ce qu'on aime
acheter et ce qu'on aime penser
l'intelligence artificielle peut aller
au delà peut fabriquer quoi une forme de
d'humain augmentée plus fonctionnel déjà
déjà il y a beaucoup de projets que vous
connaissez certainement des des grands
du numérique sur l'homme l'homme
augmenté c'est-à-dire augmenter nos
capacités être capable de
discuter avec un anglais sans connaître
l'anglais mais en traduisant
simultanément il y a plein de choses qui
sont là encore très positive moi ce que
je crains c'est que l'intelligence
artificielle Vienne concurrencer l'être
humain tel qu'il est aujourd'hui c'est à
dire que c'est une forme de perfection
le l'intelligence artificielle donc à
partir du moment où vous faites des
robots qui sont déjà en pratique mais
que vous ajoutez une intelligence
artificielle qui sera de plus en plus
développés et et de plus en plus
perfectible avoir conscience d'elle-même
elle pourrait je suis persuadé
de cette technologie là oui mais le
problème c'est que quand vous avez
quelqu'un comme Elon Musk qui est quand
même on peut le dire très leader dans
dans cette matière et qu'il dit que le
l'intelligence artificielle est
probablement le plus grand danger pour
l'homme dans les années qui viennent
vous partagez ça juste ça avec lui très
peu de choses métalliques
mais mais mais de ce point de vue là je
pense qu'il a il a parfaitement raison
c'est à dire qu'on va avoir et on le
voit bien aujourd'hui
si vous prenez un drone un drone peut
tuer sur un simple un simple ordre mais
est-ce qu'un jour il ne prendra pas
l'initiative par lui-même on ne le sait
pas donc tout ça alors bon j'exagère
évidemment parce que c'est pour les pour
les besoins de la démonstration mais je
pense que la question c'est la
conscience qu'on a d'une technologie qui
est une technologie très forte très
rapide très violente et et qui a plein
de conséquences une des conséquences
c'est le fait que les grands du
numérique considèrent que l'État est une
anomalie
on est avec des gens qui considèrent
déjà que tout que tous les politiques
même dans la politique c'est à dire la
démocratie directe tout ça on aura plus
besoin de tous ces gens là donc il y a
des mutations très très fortes qui se
mettent en place par exemple ça non plus
alors ça vous vous détestez d'abord je
déteste puis j'y crois pas trop
définitif de la découverte de l'autre de
l'al le méta vert voyage le plus grand
danger du
metabersion dans un monde parallèle
absolument c'est une immersion dans un
monde parallèle ça vous créez vous il y
a un monde qui se crée vous venez dedans
et vous développez votre personnalité à
l'intérieur de ce monde moi je pense que
c'est un
techniquement ça ça mettra des années à
devenir en revanche il y a un danger qui
est de dire aux gens ne vous inquiétez
pas si vous n'êtes pas bien dans ce
monde là ne résistez pas ne contestez
pas parce que vous avez on va vous
offrir un autre monde vous serez très
bien vous voyez ce que je veux dire et
ça je trouve ça extrêmement dangereux
alors vous parlez beaucoup des réseaux
sociaux du complotisme le cancer des
réseaux sociaux vous voilà vous n'êtes
pas tendre avec justement le projet
d'Elon musk qui est pour le moins
radical déjà on voit ce qui est à
l'oeuvre dans la manière dont il fait le
ménage au sein au sein de Twitter
parlons quand même des des raisons d'ESP
est-ce qu'il y en a encore le fameux
sursaut c'est quoi c'est une forme
d'esprit critique vous citer Albert
Camus il faut savoir s'empêcher seul
soi-même vis-à-vis des gafas des géants
du numérique est-ce qu'il faut faire
confiance à nos politiques on est à
l'Assemblée il y a des lois à
différentes échelles comment comment
essayer de se prémunir contre ça oui je
crois que cette phrase d'ailleurs qui
est attribuée à cabus mais qui je crois
était du père de de Camus qui est une
phrase qui m'a inspirait énormément être
un homme c'est savoir s'empêcher et je
pense que le que le numérique c'est tout
savoir s'empêcher parce que le
en fait le numérique flat dans notre
cerveau des pulsions qui sont des
pulsions de consommateurs et qui ne sont
pas du tout des pulsions de citoyens
donc en fait c'est
consommer indéfiniment et vous n'avez
pas fini vous avez pas fini de consommer
qu'on vous propose déjà quelque chose
d'autre et ça je pense que c'est
vraiment
c'est cette société là qui m'inquiète
aussi c'est cette société de de
déshumanisation de l'esprit critique
mais comment on fait pour l'activer pour
revenir à votre question
un peu autour de moi d'enfants qui ont
démarré très tôt un de mes fils en
particulier avec numérique qui ont été
qui se sont submergés du numérique et
qui a un moment on dit ça suffit et donc
qui reprennent les rênes donc là il y a
toujours un espoir c'est à dire que je
pense que les les générations futures
vont se rendre compte de la servissement
à une technologie dans lequel
des sociétés il y a pour terminer Marc
Dugain il y a un grand débat qui s'est
ouvert aux États-Unis sur la fermeture
de Facebook il existe ce débat même si
on voit bien les réalités d'aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il faudrait en arriver là
et moi je l'ai jamais eu mais je pense
ça serait pas une mauvaise idée merci
infiniment l'homme c'est-à-dire aux
éditions l'Observatoire et ses
coussinets avec avec le journaliste
d'investigation Christophe l'abbé c'est
une enquête c'est aussi une sorte de
récit littéraire merci vous restez avec
moi c'est l'heure d'affranchir c'est
l'heure d'accueillir nos affranchis
pardonnez-moi ce soir on va commencer
avec le regard sur le monde de Vincent
Huger qui va revenir sur les médecins
miltermes américaine Biden qui limite la
casse et Donald Trump qui rate son
come-back l'histoire du jour au Palais
Bourbon Elsa mon dingava qui nous
raconte pourquoi la présidence du groupe
d'études sur l'antisémitisme à
l'Assemblée fait l'objet d'un temps
stratation et le parti pris de l'écho
avec Fanny guinochet ce soir la grève de
trop à la SNCF c'est pour demain nos
affranchis les voici bonsoir à vous
trois on va commencer ce soir par
Vincent Vincent Hugier mitter mitigé
pour les républicains c'est un peu plus
qu'une vaguelette bien sûr mais certes
pas le tsunami la vague géante utilisé
par le bout de feu populiste Trump un
rad merrée rouge la couleur fétiche des
républicains aurait propulsé Donald vers
la présidentielle de 2024 d'autant que
de meetings euphorique en punchline
belliqueux il s'est intensément engagé
dans la campagne difficile d'imaginer
dans tel cas de figure le grand
refusait l'investiture au gourou de la
secte cyclivant soit-il et voilà que le
tremplin se fissure en quoi ces scrutin
pourrait-il altérer la confiance de
Trump plusieurs des poulains à doublé
par le milliardaire peroxydé ont mordu
la poussière a commencé par le très
inquiétant dog masturiano candidat au
fauteuil de gouverneur de la
Pennsylvanie un ancien officier adepte
de la suprême ciste proche de la
nébuleuse complotiste fascisante kiwanon
que l'on aperçu par exemple le 6 janvier
2021 lors de l'assaut sur le Capitole
dans le sillage des émeutiers en
pennsylvie toujours le démocrate John
feterman arrache un siège de sénateur au
dépend de mesmeth ose Trump Polat
impénitent qui donc en Géorgie sauf son
siège de secrétaire d'État fonction
méconnue mais cruciale puisqu'elle vous
confère l'autorité de valider les
processus électoraux c'est Brad
ruffinsperger celui-là même qui voilà
deux ans avait résisté aux injonctions
de la midonne lequel le sommet de
dénicher 11000 voix 11000 voix qui lui
manquait pour rafler cet État du sud
donc les mauvaises nouvelles viennent
aussi de son propre corps ah oui alors
le SCAR des bad news revient sans doute
au triomphe en Floride du sénateur
sortant l'ultra conservateur round de
Santi s'étoile montante de la droite
dure l'un des rivaux de Trump dans la
prochaine course à la Maison Blanche
persuadé d'ailleurs d'être investi d'une
mission divine terrasser les démons de
la culture wok et bien ce cadran n'a
même pas à l'heure du discours de
victoire daigné cité son ex mentor
lequel lui avait pourtant mis le pied à
l'étrier voilà quatre ans Donald Trump
peine en retour à masquer l'agacement
que lui inspire ce blanc bec lui aussi
au Met de le mentionner après avoir
ravalé au rang d'erreur préjudiciable au
parti le dessin prêté à 210 lui disputer
l'investiture tout aussi révélateur le
sobriquet dont il l'a fume run de 5
timonius Ron le moraliste en quelque
sorte l'histoire retiendra que c'est en
son fief floridien que commence la
croisade présidentielle de ce père la
vertu et que c'est aussi en Floride dans
son clinquant bastion de marago que
Trump dévoilera mardi prochain une très
grande annonce suspense une très grande
annonce et aussi de tout petit calcul
merci Vincent Marc Dugain vous parlez
beaucoup de Trump le héros de La Poste
vérité vous êtes un peu rassuré ce soir
de ces de cette victoire en demi teinte
franchement pour pour les républicains
un peu rassuré pas complètement mais
quand même ouais et c'est vrai que ce
qui a été formidable avec Trump c'est
cette idée que la vérité le mensonge se
valent ça c'est quelque chose qui est
totalement sociétal et qui
malheureusement nous a beaucoup envahi
bon Poutine on voit pas les choses
tellement différemment et qui nous
entraîne au bord du qui pisse de la de
la rationalité vous savez qu'il y a des
groupes d'études à l'Assemblée nationale
je sais pas si vous savez ça et c'est
très important la découverte qu'il y
avait des batailles Elsa autour de ces
groupes d'études en un en particulier
suscite beaucoup de convoitises il
s'agit d'un groupe d'études sur
l'antisémitisme le RN voudrait le
président oui tout à fait Myriam hier
s'est tenu une réunion pour parler
justement de la répartition de ces
groupes d'études il y en a près de 80 à
l'Assemblée alors c'est sur le vin sur
le handicap sur les jeux vidéo et donc
sur l'antisémitisme celui qui préside la
délégation du bureau qui s'occupe de ces
groupes d'études et bien c'est un des
vices présidents de l'Assemblée
nationale c'est Sébastien Chenu député
du rassemblement national fidèle de
Marine Le Pen alors hier pendant la
réunion il propose à chaque groupe et
bien de choisir selon une méthode qu'il
appelle le tourniquet chacun donne ses
préférences Renaissance la majorité se
positionne sur la chasse et les jeux
vidéo autour du deuxième groupe le
rassemblement national qui dit vouloir
la présidence du groupe d'études sur
l'ANT alors selon les participants c'est
un peu le choc et la surprise autour de
la table pourquoi c'est un coup
politique que veut faire le
rassemblement national alors on ne sait
pas si Sébastien Chenu avait vraiment
calculé son cours en tout cas le
rassemblement national il y a vu il y a
une opportunité pour suivre sa stratégie
des diabolisation rappelez-vous pendant
la campagne présidentielle Marine Le Pen
avait déclaré qu'elle était susceptible
de protéger le plus efficacement les
Français de confession juive la fille
essaye de faire oublier le père condamné
pour avoir comparé les chambres à gaz à
un point de détail de l'histoire de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale alors rien en
effet pour autant il y a déjà beaucoup
de réactions mais la présidence n'est
pas attribuée pour le moment non
justement il y a une liste qui a été
publiée cet après-midi elle se met un
peu le trou parce qu'elle laissait
penser que la décision était actée la
Présidence de l'Assemblée nationale a
publié un communiqué il y a El brune
pivée rappelle qu'à ce stade rien n'est
fait on est dans un processus de
concertation ce soir elle prend position
en tant que petite fille d'immigrés
juifs qui ont fui le nazisme elle
s'oppose au fait que le RN puisse
obtenir cette présidence elle l'a dit
dans une émission tout à l'heure dans la
majorité Sylvain Maillard qui représente
le groupe en l'absence d'Aurore berger
qui était présent lors de ces réunions
dit que c'est un logo il ne laissera pas
la présidente ORL ça évidemment suscité
de nombreuses réactions peut penser au
président du CRIF Yonathan Arfi si cela
devait arriver jamais le CRIF et les
institutions juives ne participeront à
cette mascarade ce serait une ineptie et
une manipulation inacceptable pareil
pour les socialistes par la voix de leur
président Boris Vallaud inconcevable
alors comment ça va se terminer est-ce
que le RN a une chance ou pas du tout
alors une prochaine réunion est prévue
le 16 novembre mercredi prochain ce qui
est sûr c'est que tous les groupes à
l'exception du RN vont contester cette
décision de toute façon Myriam
normalement c'est présidence de groupe
d'études elles doivent être validées en
bureau donc si tout le monde est contre
le rassemblement national il n'aura pas
la tête de ce groupe d'études sur
l'antisémitisme histoire de jour signer
elles amont d'un Gava vous revenez
évidemment pour nous dire
ce qu'il en est Fanny alors il y a grève
grosse grève demain à la RATP c'est dans
ce contexte qui arrive Jean Castex à la
tête de l'entreprise puisqu'il a été
nommé validé d'ailleurs par parler
députés il était auditionné aujourd'hui
ici pour lui presque une grève de
bienvenue pour l'ancien Premier ministre
alors évidemment le mot d'ordre ce sont
les hausses de salaire en ce moment il y
en a beaucoup sachant que les agents de
la RATP ont déjà obtenu 5,2 %
d'augmentation cette année en prenant en
compte les prix etc on arrive en tout
cas c'est ce que dit la direction on
arrive à ce chiffrage et puis il a RATP
la direction a aussi dit qu'elle allait
avancer les traditionnels négociations
obligatoires qui doivent se tenir
l'année prochaine et bien dès le mois de
décembre mais c'est vrai qu'à la RATP
au-delà de ça il y a un climat social
très tendu avec beaucoup d'arrêts
maladies beaucoup d'absence il y a même
quelque chose qui vient d'arriver c'est
que on paye les gens la RATP paie les
conducteurs de bus qui sont assidus qui
ne mettent pas d’arrêt maladie ce sont
les primes d'acidité alors pour des
salariés du privé on peut trouver ça
peut-être ou des chefs d'entreprise des
indépendants un peu curieux comme façon
de faire parce que les Français vont
soutenir cette grève alors c'est toute
la question auparavant on parlait de
grève par procuration c'est à dire que
les gens du les fonctionnaires les
agents du public faisaient grève parce
qu'ils étaient protégés pour les agents
du privé qui enfin les salariés du privé
qui eux ne le pouvaient pas ça c'est
terminé ça ne fonctionne plus est-ce que
les Français vont soutenir néanmoins des
grévistes qui finalement ont des hausse
de salaire supérieur au leurre parce que
quand on regarde les chiffres et bien
dans le privé en moyenne c'est toujours
une moyenne mais on est plutôt autour de
4% d'augmentation on est loin des 5%
5,ratp et encore loin des presque 6%
qu'on obtenus les agents de la SNCF
parce que eux aussi demain sont en grève
donc il faut voir si les Français vont
être tolérant face à cette grève si on
regarde un dernier conflit social
c'était à Total l'opinion était très
clivée et oui c'était moitié-moitié
c'était très partagé il y avait d'un
côté les gens qui estimaient que les
grévistes avaient raison et puis les
autres qui disaient ben non ils nous
empêche de travailler ce sont finalement
des privilégiés il gagne pas si mal leur
vie mais c'est vrai que le conflit total
c'était très particulier total c'est pas
une entreprise qui est très aimée des
Français c'est une entreprise qui est
perçue comme polluante on parle de
bénéfices de chiffres records de
milliards d'euros engrangé là la SNCF la
RATP c'est différent c'est un peu le
patrimoine des Français et puis tout le
monde constate tous les jours quand on
est usagé que bien le service il y a pas
beaucoup d'argent ou en tout cas les
investissements ne sont pas là que
l'État remet au poids à chaque fois et
derrière ce sont nos impôts alors le
risque quand même je pense c'est que ce
mouvement social soit perçu comme une
expression corporatiste de quelques
agents qui ont un statut encore protégé
parce que tout ça se fait en plus sur
fond deux réformes prête à venir ou en
tout cas on va demander des efforts aux
salariés du privé on n'est pas encore
sûr que les régimes spéciaux soient eux
aussi à supprimer ou en tout cas que le
concerné par la réforme merci beaucoup
Fanny on verra si c'est la grève de trop
ou pas aux yeux des
usagers merci à vous merci Marc Duguin
d'avoir été avec nous dans cette
émission je rappelle le titre de votre
livre l'homme sans contact c'est aux
éditions de l'Observatoire coécrit avec
Christophe Labbé merci les affranchis
paniquer de Chelles la matinale de
France Info l'édito-éco bien sûr allez
on va citer nos confrères LCI vous
chroniquer jour après jour le conflit en
Ukraine Vincent et ma conso préférée qui
m'accompagne Elsa si elle s'est fait
très belle soirée documentaire à demain
[Musique]